the price of polluters permits is at an
all-time low the European emissions
trading system is in his death throes
the economic crisis has hit it hard
companies are producing less and have
less need for emission allowances the
price of a ton of co2 has plummeted and
now stands at around the four to five
euro mark ideally a ton should cost
between 25 to 30 euros to encourage
companies to invest in greener
technologies the European Parliament's
Environment Committee supports the idea
of artificially raising prices how by
temporarily and conditionally taking 900
million co2 emission allowances off the
market if we would not have done this
the prize with so low that many an
investment that are necessary would have
been put on hold the idea of reducing
the supply of co2 allowances on the
market isn't new and for that matter had
previously been rejected by the European
Parliament so why approve it in
committee today seasonic a luminance of
a position on the rig velocity on then
and alleged Markov tomorrow into rehab
Norfolk Eden a punk de Souza Lima common
vm he say sveck pinned under 600 million
and becky loaded an amendment allowances
of the 900 million frozen allowances 600
million will be earmarked for a fund
that will support among other things the
development of green technologies some
companies however don't look favorably
upon an increase in co2 prices believing
that the current economic situation
doesn't allow them to spend any more